I'll chew gum read my name it's
beautiful
welcome back to some more animation I've
actually been told by the Creator I was
supposed to go up and that's my
girlfriend's phone calling than that
laughter how come I didn't notice it
yesterday
god damn I must have been drunk but why
don't you cook whatever or maybe not ah
genius all right whatever let's just
keep going in here that looks like a dog
I'm just putting it out there that
little crack there all right come party
in here but ain't no party like a pupa
ha ha
you must leave this dungeon this castle
and my arms are huge leave now while I
still have to find your way my dad what
are you doing up there you now you go
and never come back never whoa what the
hell oh okay cool Oh No what my dad what
did i do I didn't do anything all right
that's you lovely all right that's cool
why are you dying my 10 minutes
[ __ ] me like come here all right that's
cool I didn't want to really go ahead
anyway
all right right god damn ruler naked
[ __ ] me wait wait wait wait old man
study good am i done in here I'm gonna
I'm gonna I don't even I hope that was
correct laughs I that's a day to be not
that is a question but what locked all
right this better work ah ah that did
not work very well payday I don't know
why but you suck at this
I know it's not my fault yes yes and
that's your fault
fine I'm going here I think this is the
right one
nope this [ __ ] me god damn it
frigging tar sub-period beautiful
gorgeous nice I'm out of oil that's okay
that doesn't matter as long as we're
have each other
that's the only thing no big projects
around here and the sledgehammer how do
you forget about me don't set some oil
for me I want that [ __ ] thank you
alright locked oh yeah
let's go I like about never not been in
here already
I'm super confused I like that ah I'm
sure it's fine freakin old man and
they're all down I'm screwed potatoes
why are you here potatoes I'm Tom [ __ ]
okay cool
I thought you were something else what
is this painting doing here
get off me do I really have to look
everywhere I don't know about this
situation let me take that okay I'm
sorry
how's that me I have a tick I can't help
it
what the hell what happened
Wow
what is this whoa whoa I'm trippin balls
ma what are you doing here
get off me you tell I don't care what
you what happened there what the hell i
doesn't out aah aah aah sorry auntie why
do you doubt if I you made a mess
Jennifer I know
you can take it mr. schaerr ain't happy
there you are my love you are my what
are you doing in them I'm tired just
like to merge good things you know and I
will never ever ever be a fine wit why
does his Santa Claus hat doing here that
mean something bad is gonna happen I
don't like whoa this is pretty awesome
hell's going on here Oh Martin what am i
doing what are you writing my essay
I'll fight you off from the breakdancing
moves oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah you see
that
works every time take this lap two three
questions Bridget machi goddamnit I
supposed to go
alright Casa de maqam PA for you
got it all right back in the forest I
guess why did I go back in the forest
I'm picky I got a king I got a key not a
problem but I didn't get really anything
else that's okay I thought if you're
having fun when you do it I'm just
finding it out
all right stop door don't [ __ ] with me
door I [ __ ] you up the urge I slap my
balls on you that's right
balls slap it's a new thing new thing
new thing what it's not new but you
actually slap someone with your balls
that's just gross yeah
you slap your vajayjay on someone that
is just like what I hear why would you
slap someone with the earth whether you
sleep alright you must have a pretty big
vagina happy for you
alright so please like this be the key
blasted god damnit good thing is locked
they they us such an idiot
I am teleporting back here because
Tattaglia god dammit I was told by a
little birdy Karla Nelly Furtado I'm
real actor I was Flyway I didn't know
where my owner is there it is I don't
know where my potatoes right here but
why did you tell me I been looking
everywhere for him this is orange Hara
do you want the potatoes oh he didn't
want to potatoes goddamn orange aura I
think we need to go back yeah maybe
haha scream like a woman that's it all
here's the door Jesus crying guest
quarters
no it's why for sugar I like the sound
of door alright that was best door sound
effect ever and you know it I know it
because you wrote it down my do didn't
take notes oh we're screwed
here we go I have not been here before
our god dammit I love things painting
it's my favorite activity fantastic
hello
whoa whoa whoa I'm trippin balls what is
all this
too much - oh yay
Marvin the painting over here please
work oh [ __ ] yeah I need it what yeah I
could break open that door well then
[ __ ] I don't have the power
I could pry this door open if I had a
crowbar oh god damn it I don't have one
I have been kind of lost for a while
haha why y'all I could jump did you see
that strong hammer but I don't have any
of these things why am I here I'm
starting to question
whoa doors until you doing here doors
whoa whoa what doors what is all this
lovely Alice Bailey I am the rest I can
see you're not the real safale don't
come oh no that door exploded I am
stronger than I like all right cool call
that night no not you again it looks
like it rusted shut his butt no no come
closer nice poses buddy whoa he's like
look at this right I know this one god
damn you active toes whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa everyone need to take no no
Oh Oh not funny not funny
look what I did to Jesus I got damn it
all right let me crawl over here
nice ceilings all right to have more
keys so for whatever [ __ ] reason were
they even booked that damn god damn you
[ __ ] finger-painting they do is not
more not tomorrow
it's okay Santa I mean it's how you what
is this and Octopussy all right said
tree I usually get those mixed up and
it's quite the embarrassment in school
at sixth grade when we were writing a
report about trees I wrote about an
octopus yeah I wrote this note to my
family I am an old man living in hell I
lost my wife last year since then this
grave gives me the creep I am sitting on
my bed in a weird position and it made
my ball sleepy what have I done to
suffer all this I just don't understand
what am i starving to recently one of
them asked me for a lockpick maybe he
just back went long I better tell him
the pain transition Aaron I better check
the painting in the room mmm naylet ha
you were like what is this I can't
understand this I can't comprehend
I need a genius translator well then you
have my mind right here
all right let's party over here
no party like a where am I
pause play mahjong Emma all right
mansion there's this party machine I am
all right cool
I all wanted to go to the party at my
Chanel it's a small house I need to go
in there before I go into the magic
that's awesome
that's where I'm safe at least that's
where these notes are telling me all
right well I see it's a small house
Matthew's a small house let's use the
smaller
I don't like Oh another one
all right all right god that's gonna see
if you're done it doesn't work the first
time try another couple Tahoe god damn
it all bad not [ __ ] when they die why
is nothing working today
oh that's a pot oh no oh it's still
alive oh there we go
whoa nice position pot all right well
everyone
better open one of these days doors
what are you oh I even see it because I
was yeah the strong odor of wine is
coming from behind that shallot
but what are you hiding from a what is
that you're hiding you're hiding
something I nut
don't hide liquor from me [ __ ] cool
thunderstorm [ __ ] alright let's go up
here oh no hi this is way too high for
me let's go this way
there we go oh sorry let me get three
this not there's servants please
remember always close to the secret
passage don't forget to activate by the
lever underneath alright that's a hint I
love it stop wasting I'm not wasting
anything there we go ah oh you're the
door who [ __ ] with me you pack one main
door that was it where's voicecrack ever
heading puberty that's cool so what is
this
bunny I'm a bunny I love you Pete I know
you love me do a jump buddy do a jump do
it all right but I can't I can't I'm
scared not a lot of people watching do
it [ __ ] do it
I don't want to I know what please don't
make me deaf do I do it [ __ ] job Eric
there we go
you just got it I don't know what what
you have to do open goddamn whoa what
the hell is that that's a clock but I
think I read a notes about this puzzle
let's see here a little radar then you
will see here I feel quite bad share on
the table the clock in the counter sure
so I can of clock Jesus what a pity
grab my nipples goddamn it perverted
Jesus why did I go here why now but
there has to be something study room key
as a riddle thing
better check the painting in the room
a lot [ __ ] painting in my [ __ ]
room I I will end this episode I
recorded for pretty long but like maybe
shooting guys this guy to cover bread
today and I'll see you next episode of
whatever I am a don't shoot him yes
that's right you are hopeless what are
you deaf I thought I would be but if I'm
not gonna die